who is this not an exceptional
circumstance which would have been
allowed by the rules no not at all I
mean this really is behavior which I
think most people would find quite
extraordinary
you know we faced the situation that
we've been told by the government that
we must have be the rules and at this
time that it was about staying warm it
was about protecting the NHS and setting
lights we were not supposed to engage in
any non-essential travel and indeed the
Prime Minister had gone on national
television and told us that we should be
protecting grandparents that they
shouldn't be looking after grandchildren
Dominic Cummings really has to accept
his responsibilities for what he's done
in breaking lock donors should resign
but there are also questions for the
Prime Minister because we now know that
figures in Downing Street knew about
this so my question is the Prime
Minister does when did you know about
this did you sanction it why haven't you
taken action against Dominic Cummings
earlier and if Dominic Cummings wouldn't
do what is the right thing and resign
then the Prime Minister has to show
leadership and he should be telling him
that he has to go you know we faced the
situation that other figures in public
life Neil Ferguson and of course in
Scotland Catherine Colbert is had to go
because they broke lockdown rules but
this is a man that knew what he was
doing
the traveled 250 miles and of course we
also know in this issue of the cover-up
that his wife Mary Wakefield wrote
articles explaining how Dominic Cummings
was isolating at home we now know that
this was very far from the truth that
simply isn't acceptable and let's not
forget this is the Prime Minister's
closest adviser that has had a
significant impact in developing the
policy and the rules of the rest of us
are living by and it does create the
impression that there's one law for the
rich and powerful when there's a another
law for the vast bulk of the people
living in the United Kingdom it's not
right it's not acceptable you nominate
Cummings you forgive me but you've got
to be you've got you've got to be
careful before jumping the gun are on
this until we get the full details
because on the 23rd of March at the
briefing the deputy chief medical
officer did say that if you were seeking
child care whilst you were ill that is
classed as an exceptional circumstance
well you have to look at what is
proportionate and the simple fact of the
matter is that that definition of what
is acceptable doesn't involve driving
251 miles and also the specific guidance
that the Prime Minister had given the
grandparents elderly relatives had to be
protected and it most certainly
shouldn't be looking after grandchildren
so I'm afraid that one wash and you know
we've had the situation that other
leaders in the Conservative Party not
least Jackson Carlo and Scotland said
that there can't be one rule for bosses
and another for everyone else I know
Jackson Carr was quite right
Dominic Cummings quite simply has the
door and he should go right now so what
should have been done under those
circumstances then if you've got a
couple who were they were both ill with
Kovac 19 or also they suspected and
don't feel they're able to look after
their young child what should they have
done but of course the arrangements have
to be put in place but it's not for me
to Theodore Gannett Cummings what I
should be doing for these chamkila
arrangements but I would respectfully
suggest that driving 250 miles isn't
acceptable and certainly going to visit
grandparents of the children isn't
acceptable and he knows that this is
about what's right and what's wrong
and that's the judgment that people up
and down the United Kingdom will be
making today but here we have an
individual right at the heart of
government an individual who is devising
the rules that the rest of us have to
follow has wilfully broken those rules